some of the nation's bravest dogs are
being honored for their courage five
military dogs received the canine medal
of courage last night on Capitol Hill
the award goes to canines that show
extraordinary valor in their service
chip Reid is on Capitol Hill with one of
the award winners chip good morning
well good morning this is jag and he's
completely focused on his partner Denis
Dowell over there who you'll meet in
just a moment and he is one jaga's one
of five winners last night of the
American Humane canine medal of courage
you ready jag served in Afghanistan
alongside his now owner retired Army
sergeant Dennis Dow I bet you would have
a hard time describing yourself as a
hero I'm not but I bet you'd have no
trouble saying he's a hero absolutely
can you find bombs with your nose Dowell
says his relationship with jag wasn't
love at first sight but they bonded
while working together in war zones he
came under fire oh yeah oh yeah we did
did he understand the seriousness of
that absolutely not in no way shape or
form it's just having a good time damn
right after Dowell retired the two best
friends were separated while Jag
continued his service how hard was it
for you to give him up I shut down I
shut myself down but they were later
reunited Dow and his wife Jacqueline say
jag is now helping Dow cope with severe
PTSD what would life be like today if
there had been no jag I probably would
be a widow and be raising my children by
myself jag was honored for his military
service Tuesday night on Capitol Hill
with the k-9 medal of courage we also
met summer one of the other Award
winners a 7-year old yellow lab and her
current coworker retired Air Force
sergeant Michael Jones
the pair are a TSA explosive detection
team working for Amtrak police do you
have the best job in the world good I
would have to say yes in part he says
because he gets to spend all day with
his best friend at times I have training
and
and I had to leave her at home it's it's
horrible before working in Washington
some are served in Afghanistan when she
was in the war zone she came under fire
yes sir
where her bomb-sniffing saved the lives
of countless Marines when you heard that
she's going to be honored with a canine
medal of Courage Award what did you
think I had to call everybody and their
brother to tell them about it was
exhilarating it was exhilarating and a
pretty proud of her
amen yes sir well jag and Dennis Dale
spent about a year and a half in a
combat zone but this is what they do now
Dennis give me 10 seconds of what you
guys spend your time doing now Egypt
okay come on buddy Oh ready you still
want the ball okay GUP whoa don't down
ready tell me if you want it come on
Terry
as you can see a highly disciplined
military dog well jag is a highly
disciplined military dog but he's now
retired and loving life and so is Dennis
now gal yeah it's a good story for
everybody all around and I think they
had the best question for you chip can
you sniff out bombs with your nose no
you can yeah so congrats to jack that's
the most fun they've had on Capitol Hill
in a long time yes that's right yeah
there you go